hey it's stephanie and today i'm super
excited to talk about sharing and
monetizing data using apis
let's get into it
[Music]
in this modern digital world powered by
smart iot devices
hundreds of petabytes of data are
generated every second as consumers
increasingly prefer online shopping
mobile banking telehealth and other
digital services
on the other hand organizations are
looking to harness the power of this
data
using tools like google cloud bigquery
to deliver personalized experiences
make data-driven business decisions
improve organizational efficiency
and unlock new revenue however there are
several challenges in putting data into
action
these include data residing in silos
security concerns over sharing
proprietary data
and the complexity of monetizing data
consumption
this is where apis can help by packaging
data as api
products you can create a standardized
way to aggregate data across systems
securely share data with other teams and
external partners
and create rate plans and build for the
consumption of data
let's take a closer look
in this demo we are going to use apogee
to easily consume and monetize a large
set of weather data from bigquery
so the first step is to use apigee to
create an api
which pulls this data if you look at
this api proxy setup
we configured it to fetch all the
necessary weather data from a bigquery
backend target let's take a closer look
at the api proxy
you'll see that there are many things a
proxy can add while fetching the
information requested
it can secure the api do rate limiting
caching and get a token to authenticate
the bigquery api
and on the return flow you can reformat
the bigquery response
so that it's easier to consume
after creating the apigee proxy the next
step is to create an
api product for this demo
i created a weather api product and you
can see
that this product uses the same weather
api that we built earlier
this product also has a rate plan
associated with it for monetization
purposes
it helps bill the user for every api
call made to fetch weather data
from bigquery when you click
on this rate plan you can see the
pricing details of 12 cents for every
api call made
now let's switch roles and take a look
at how an api consumer
would sign up to use this weather api
and get billed for it
the first step would be to visit the
apigee developer portal and view all the
apis
then i can go over to buy apis pick a
subscription that best suits my
requirements
and review the pricing information the
next step would be to create a client
app
that uses a weather api product
i created an app called weather client
when you click on it
you can see the consumer key which
identifies this client app
now that i have an authorized app to
access the api
let's test this api and see how i get
billed for consumption
for that let's go to the api
documentation
and click on the weather api here you
can see the endpoint
required parameters body of the api and
other details
[Music]
let's test out this api you can enter
the city
and api key that has been granted and
executed to fetch all the weather
stations near santa monica
from bigquery
let's take one of these weather stations
and make another api call
over here to get the temperature let's
enter the same api key
choose a year enter one of the weather
stations that we got from the previous
api call
and click execute this gives me the
temperature of
every day in 2015 at santa monica
from bigquery since i made two api calls
let's now see how much i was built for
this consumption
let's go to the analytics view and look
at the custom report i created
this report shows the overall traffic if
i chose a specific developer
you can see that two api calls were made
and were billed 24 cents since each call
was configured for 12 cent
in summary apigee makes it simple and
easy to package your business data as
apis
this allows you to securely share with
other teams and partners as well as
monetize for additional revenue
now it's your turn to try it out and get
started by following the links in the
description below
[Music]
you